first of all medea came out of
retirement for this film and she's been
performing at coachella i've seen them
picks up the super bowl she's going to
bust the hips she's doing a lot honey
how did it feel
being on set again
you remind me so much of journeys millet
um
your voice and everything um you know it
felt it felt great to warm her up again
my whole point in bringing her back and
out of retirement is for i was you know
watching the state of the world and how
sad we are and the pandemic politics
everything i'm saying what can i do to
make us laugh and this is the
best tool i've had my toolbox so i
pulled her out and here we are
you teased this movie with parodies of
oprah and beyonce what were
reactions sound so much like
sound
their
have you listened to her no now you're
gonna make me good luck listen to
journey smaller you your speaking voice
is almost the same it's amazing i'm
sorry uh beyonce and oprah what were you
what was your question
you teased this movie with parodies of
oprah and beyonce but what was their
reaction like
oh listen they both love it they both
thought it was hilarious
and and once i got queen b's approval
then i was good to go so yeah
and and they did exactly what i want the
world to do they just laugh when they
saw it yeah oh i was laughing um who
breaks
character more because knickers in a
bunch
was
deceased
yeah yeah yeah i think we all did in
that moment i remember talking to
brendan on the phone and he said
something about knickers i said what'd
you say knickers and and i said oh i got
to put that in the movie and and to have
that reaction and you know the
misunderstanding of the word i think a
lot of that may be happening out out in
the world so yeah it was really a lot of
fun yeah
who would you say breaks character more
hmm
i don't know listen we all are trying to
crack each other up so but brendan got
me got me a lot of times even brown even
bam some of the things they're saying
it's it's really
it's just a group of really brilliantly
funny people so there's a lot of
breaking up
given that this is medea's first
original film for netflix does that
allow for less limitations like does
this feel like medea uncensored could
you go further
no i've already i've always felt like i
could do what i want but i've always
pulled her back a little bit but in this
time in this instance and where we are
in the world i decided to push it a
little bit further but also
understanding that in cinema i only have
you know so many theaters with netflix
we're all around the world at once so
i'm speaking to more than just my normal
audience which is really really exciting
for me and although i love love love my
audience to expand it and the
possibility of that really gives me
great hope yeah there are so many
important discussions in this film as
well it's hilariously funny but they're
important discussions as always medea
always does a good job at this but you
know we discussed police brutality um
social injustice issues and even the
lgbtq plus storyline was done so
wonderfully um why is that important to
you to include well i just i don't want
to just make people laugh and just let
that be that i mean let's let's talk
about some things the laughter is only
the anesthetic to talk about some things
that are really plaguing us that we need
to consider and talk about and i've
spent so much time with uh you know kids
who have been put out because they were
uh gay or came out to their family and
and i've worked with covenant house over
the years and having hearing some of
these stories were heartbreaking so i
just wanted to just give us an
opportunity to say hey hold on a minute
let's rethink all of this and see what
happens yeah
are we going to see like medea
crossovers on netflix like is this the
official expansion of like medea
cinematic universe like what's going on
i don't know i don't know we'll see
we'll see i listen i i absolutely love
working with them i love the team and if
you ever got a chance to really sit in a
room with with some of these executives
you'd be
blown your mind would be blown at the
diversity that's around the table i love
that thank you for your time tyler we
need an e.t canada studio visit yeah
we'll have to make that happen at the
same time you go and just listen to
journeys mullet do an interview and
listen to her voice
without her or any visuals of it it'll
blow your mind i'm gonna go do it right
now okay okay
all right okay bye tyler